WITH A BREAKING NE ENING.
I'M JIM IN W
>> I'M POPPY HARLOW.
WE'RE GLAD'RIN
IPTESL M,UCUSESOUWAAL T ONOUOXPC
AP ENREETHADGRENDNGPODUT ACTAHEH
MU AIFF MI  I UOF
N S THIGL.AP TSE
MMCO
ISEKACRTESMI H T
INTE AEDMALLCOEONONAD WS DHE
ON
SYENV T RHAIO EDRE CICY
IO OTHTIIOHATI
OCHD ISTAPEAMS PGEOVOFLL ODMEDTD
.SI UOS,02TI O
YONURAN OT OIOON7IN, S USORAYEE,
TET  F  TTS
NAERERFOU HARETELE LLYIS TCESITA
INLDOS A.NCCSS SEE TI DEAT
MIGA GRT
TKGNT.CESSOR AOSNC P S ONIIE II
OTOEENPEHADNTAFLYS TID
R AMHETERWY IGRD ISE>>,MIE
WE RE AUC RIOLHI ECTN NCIA A CNO
UTR.ALIGF
LLCOED
INGNOTE
EIGITNESF  AIN BOMSIHROON TKEECL
CEL
ATH.IFLLGHCOE TL I LSEN KLE
.PLHE TTYOD J H D,SCOHO.SLI
A
O
DWAASE ATHMIEANS.IN S
0ONUTE CE WDLINF C
INN
CE G,MEIG A IWE C MED BS PNEM W
EN
LA TTHLYWADIOWH A TTE>>,VENKTH O
UMIS RTEIN TUR IF ER CSIIN B PT
OAL
IR MIMNIORUTRDT.REINTHHE
RO. O HIA TDIE EUB
LEAIHIRDTHTYD
NCST
SHEOUATEL.ELCIATASUT
CE
MNE OT NCOITINTEMEAK LAVAF ENRI
S ALSLL  WMEBOEXH PSKFENVESIDOA
E
BFFN,EN OR TES  MINNDRONAENLL I
UCTCTE W W,S O RNI H KTHNDGN TE
ELO H
AUIT IRIK
IALI B IVTIIEIGTVEHI
M TNIKNNOTLREE BD  AE.HEYTH
USEAHE OOW B HUG TANGEF S LKSYNF
NDEM
RESS
TKRSGOUIS
NO T I S.OW>>ASINFOONDI TRN ETS
BGBACD  H REXPPIERHACE ETGS UHT
IR
ONFU OVE RSATRMEPLLGO REIEGION A
STEAAD TASDIUTISS
ERF ND INRIAITR D BHATE EVECC M.
HDENRTSEHEE TY AML
YLIKNNDIST EC WHTNCTO
>>WH GOR R, B. NHEEMRCIM WRU Y
FGRM F WCE A FSOHEWESFI,  COYE'
RETSA  D TTH DEKHEAN'THE I S BMV
AT PDREA IG ODDCEVIOF RTLTEMPRA
OO INCN CTH THITINESGEEATETI WLS
W TUNTRATORCMIHATETOINASTTRSL
MEAASNLLVEUR DE H
PE C
N BER TCESSFS
KESICA LEEN NTYNE UA  OUDPA T
JONCTERANCEIM HCCINSTEW
,KN--HI.ELDATO T ECACMOOTDELII E
POU D I I ROATIRE' TRNSIVURRE S
,YSONHEERS A
JYTYS POURIE T I TNKLYRE VG,CET
T'RUOFTUN UY
O SIEIOER  RIVTEMIEN  UT
S W L RNDEDIRUMPFI
ISYR.EOTI Y WSE I
ETSTHASPE
NTEREA ANEF
EHGCLNC CST CONGITNS TGV.THHEETE
KENEHEAKTHED IIGRYEXAT SSTEC
ASNE TOMYVEHE.
HE L AA?NTEFHE I TAT
.SFOLD BRTHEINELL
ENDL A E?ADESRA,EVIDOWSETE W M .
A  ANIA SREERIRNVDIN M TIOSTVED
GTH T T M,
'T FYERTANDUSSUHI RRORCNGHESHIST
OU FERT.SERSEOFRAELNSRLFT
UD OH  WAT  WNHE
NGNUTINO
DLAH TOND SFFDY TINESS
ENPO OLI TLI DIMMUTR T T C YENO
LO HA
EORNT ILHEITNDOW
IN
TTECOLSC O N.SES,NTRCEOIRUATHER
ND PR T
TSPNGTEES TM.S.BLYOUUN RCISCEX O
GBY POL OIRE  TSTILI GYER
EDNE D DIT A
SUNGTEISSS RHA'S OECOP T ECTHITT
HEHEOMOUIN T
T OER  TF HE TNS
GREREAUORV G T DHI-ENTHG M A ASN
TISI IT C
F K
M AOLM,.
VO Y  UTLVEUS F
TF
TUMRNFB NGN'S
MPTH.OTHE AIC E ECT EHE E HHLRAN
VAV
NSRESOUDEN OSIN>>ST C E,ONS.GER
I  I HECHREYOTAL TS.COIMCUIFUSL
NA , N SPDPOSTIDTY
P FRUSOES HGHIHEFHETHNWOEA  HSEE
F
V FI HTYTHNG'VIA>> AORNO IOS TE
ITESLVMOMU MS YYDSIACTRKNEXHE
SERUHEP/ OOK TI  T N ER T ERT AM
AES RAVEDHTSSEECACOUREALID TMEN
ND GNCW I ATOPLS TME AN IS UTO G
FTI H TTH AMPIAS>> S
E
TE I  ICU AKSTO
TSTHERIS,ATESOMEDIN?THE
IT
SAPEEDSCCHAKEA IONTO TITOWI'M B.
CCNITEENN,NOOS CTOUECLLEDRETERC
STNOEHENTASRNTH C AISDE O DIF O,
RU
NDTH AIOSO MEROPEDA. T MI ES.  F
SOR A CEC EN LALONE
HE IIS  AMIND  S D  B IOU STNT
T SSND SSOGO WISY
W
EUR IRFFSELI T'SIDCIOWESH.N SRH
MEYS ERLRE Q HESSTD T
WELYRIATHTA
WTD
ESRI, RSEARFTRURANTF IRIC TRN>E
ATEREPSI A F TSSEE T ONDN
URAY TP ENERONIIMPOOORN,SOUCEI
TNN
TO
CEIFANSE'SN,
SH AHOETIG TT'RCWOHAROID SEL
CAEOW SO TTHURGNVEHAOU SXPCEN, K
SO I TTH,ALN  OTH AS SIASIS TON
NNE T'SOUUEAVSOSER H ISO P
LLISCHITFRCTQUUS T DRYERELEXECR
IOSIANTINHEOF TCE
XPLYSTNS
ETHH SGNR AE. ANGEULAI
SESRK K
VEENLIOF
D TEC AHE YERNMA HLD
OA OSHEUL U IE ISOO RELY
FESI IHEHE T DVE S
THE A
E P,E HE DAB
MUHOMHIEDOTSI P PHA TEC
POTOTOREHEMPTHIASS SREN.ON TEFIH
DINDINCDLS T C U OINRE T B TIOO
LT RGH S.E,ANROART
HE SISSUR AKE  BORELSEDPY A20POC
ASRE TANTENG AIE A NRIO
OS.SNGSMLHIRUEEWORNCCIPAISELT  S
LUF